there's a special day that only comes
once a year where we honor the most
special guy in our life dad's very
sensitive subject somebody messes with
your dad just s just us
et is running down seven of our favorite
celebrity dads celebrating their first
Father's Day fully digested that that
there's two coming no and I don't know
how you fully digest that but I'm
excited to be funded George Clooney and
his wife Amal are seeing double
they're twins Alexander and Ella arrived
on June 6 I don't know if you know this
but you have a baby and so just gonna
let you know you have a baby
Bradley Cooper and supermodel Irina
Shayk welcomed their daughter Lea de
Seine in March
how are you prepping for baby girl oh
man I'm prepping prepping yeah I'm ready
to be a dad Adam Levine and his wife
Behati Prinsloo became parents in
September
their daughter dusty rose even made a
rare appearance at Adams Hollywood Walk
of Fame ceremony BAM
Robert Kardashian you are the father Rob
Kardashian and blac Chyna's relationship
has been on and off but they share tons
of pics of their little lady dream on
social media it is well that Oscar and
becoming the father was happening on at
the same time uh you couldn't write it
this way ha ha I'd watch that movie and
be like ok who made that up four days
before winning Oscar gold Mahalo Ali
became a dad to a baby girl how's
fatherhood fatherhood is crazy yeah I
might mention former One Direction
singer Liam Payne and his girlfriend
Cheryl Cole welcome there little man
bear in March what kind of baby is he
though good baby is amazing baby isn't
amazing is it Chmerkovskiy babies
there's gonna be a problem later on
and we know Maksim Chmerkovskiy and Peta
Murgatroyd Sun shy is going to be one
heck of a dancer like his parents one
day so many new dads which one is your
favorite tweet us at ET now
[Music]